[Música]
muchísimas gracias por continuar en la
pantalla de france 24 seguimos en 5
minutos y nos acompaña hoy roberto
baquero el ex presidente del colegio
médico colombiano con el vamos a hablar
sobre la vuelta a la normalidad con la
reapertura de la mayoría de las
actividades en el país aunque esto se da
en medio de una cierta incertidumbre por
el cob y 19 precisamente cuando la
nación sobrepasa los 20 mil muertos y
los 624 mil contagiados doctor vaquero
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros
muy buenos días para ti y para toda tu
audiencia doctor bueno colombia llega la
reapertura
precisamente superando las 20.000
muertes por el virus del cob y 19 como
evalúa en este contexto a ustedes esta
medida de reapertura
pues mira hay que tener en cuenta dos
cosas uno es la parte médica en la cual
pues en colombia se ha logrado se había
venido logrando controlarla el pico de
la pandemia para poderse preparar y
tener las unidades de cuidado intensivo
listas para poder atender a la gente y
que no hubiera o no un exceso de demanda
y eso se logró nosotros siempre
propusimos seguir un bastante de cerca
con la cuarentena del gobierno nacional
y el y el local acá en bota decidieron
seguir adelante con estas aperturas y
con una cuarentena sectorizadas que
después nos han estado como demostrando
que si les ha funcionado que se han
logrado controlar claro que esto
preocupa porque en colombia
lamentablemente no somos tan juiciosos
en usar bien los implementos de
bioseguridad y hacer todo lo que se debe
hacer y cuál es el doctor la situación
en este momento de los trabajadores del
sector de la salud en colombia y también
del sistema sanitario en el país para
continuar enfrentando la pandera
en este contexto
pues mira en cuanto al sistema sanitario
lo que estamos mirando si se logró
preparar para poder no llegar a una
copada de los servicios el problema así
ha sido el personal de la salud que
lamentablemente esto es lo que ha
demostrado es las condiciones
inequitativas en que estamos siendo
contratados porque estamos des laboral
izados aún todavía no nos dan todos los
implementos de bioseguridad
hemos sufrido agresiones que es una cosa
que es ilógica que las personas que
están defendiendo a la población sean
agredidas exactamente por esta profesión
hacía precisamente usted de referencia a
estos doctor cuales son con más en
concreto las condiciones laborales y
también salariales de los trabajadores
de la salud en colombia
si en esto ha habido hace mucho tiempo
no había una actualización y en colombia
el máximo problema que hay es que la
mayoría de todo el recurso humano en
salud está contratado por lo que se
llama órdenes de prestación de servicios
que es una manera de contratar a
personal pero que es según lo que dice
la ley ilegal porque no es una manera
laboral no a una estadía laboral y sólo
se puede usar para lo que son
digamos profesiones o empleos no
misionales lo que quiere decir esto si
yo ofrezco medicina general pues todos
los médicos generales tienen que estar
contratados de una manera o de la
oralización acá no acá seguimos por otro
pero es que no deja nunca una
estabilidad laboral y lo que hemos visto
es que han habido muchos despidos ya ha
habido también rebaja en los salarios de
los profesionales y en recursos humanos
en salud que es ilógico que ocurre en
este momento de pandemia en que estamos
afrontando esto doctor nos queda menos
de un minuto pero no quiero dejar de
preguntarle cuáles han sido las
principales dificultades no en estos
meses sobre todo con
gestión del personal sanitario
si lo que hemos estado hablando que no
había los implementos de bioseguridad
hoy en día ya después de más de dos
meses seguimos teniendo problemas el
tema de no incapacidades que cuando se
aísla al personal de la salud no se le
está reconociendo en capacidad ante la
sospecha si aparece infectado sí pero sí
aparecen negativos no se les reconoce y
el tema de no pago de los salarios
tenemos casos aberrantes en colombia
como un médico atendiendo coronavirus
murió y le de bien todavía cinco meses
de salario como de hospitales que en un
año de salario y no pasa nada eso es lo
que nosotros sí estamos muy ocupados
roberto baquero muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en france 24 a nuestra
audiencia como siempre les decimos que
continúen cuidándose mucho en la medida
de lo posible
continúen informando se en france 24 y
en france 24 punto com
[Música]